le témoignage de fabienne sa mère
biologique qui nous a raconté sa
relation avec claude françois est là
c'est qu'on prend cette histoire et
science qu'elle n'était âgée que de 13
ans c'est incroyable avec élèves à
raison il s'en vanter c'est ouf
regardez si c'est incroyable je ne lui
ai jamais indiqué mon âge je faisais
plus âgés donc c'est vrai que j'étais
jeune mais à l'époque c'était un autre
contexte c'était les années après 68 et
il est interdit d'interdire donc on le
voyait le mal nulle part et heureusement
qu'aujourd'hui le monde a changé et que
on est beaucoup plus plus conscients de
wade de tout ce qui peut s'ensuivre
c'était très for lire à ce qui n'en fait
et sait aussi trouver sur un événement
douloureux de sa vie le jour où il a
retiré son enfant
si vous pensez de ça parce que mine de
rien c'est incroyable sanitaires et elle
avait 13 ans fabienne gilles moi je suis
choqué quand même parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y avait un contexte particulier à
l'époque ah oui mais vraiment lâche 13
ans c'est pas possible quoi bien et
l'impunité qui l'a eu mais je trouve que
ces deux femmes témoins avec une
sincérité dans les yeux sont humides à
cette émission d'habitude mais là ça m'a
bouleversé
aujourd'hui j'aime lire une salle au
bout et toujours pas empêché non je fais
mon mea culpa ça m'a bouleversé en
continu sur le toutes les personnes un
peu plus seniors oui les hercules c-130
les propos de claude françois sur les
femmes et notamment les femmes très
jeunes gagnants il dit clairement de 13
ans à 17 ans elle m'intéresse
après se met à penser ne m'intéresse
plus et elle non plus elles sont moins
fraîches il le dit les gars alors
isabelle ardon excusez moi oui mais quoi
on à gilles verdez qui parlent de
scandale à chaque fois car un chanteur
dans un boy's qu'elle aura été une année
avant
alors là par contre là une jeune femme
qui a 13 ans qui fait un enfant avec
claude françois alors certes c'est un
grand nom c'est une des plus grosses
bien dire non mais attends mais là tu tu
m'aimes tu te donne même pas tu dis même
pas que ça à ce qu'on a c'est
dégueulasse par doit évidemment les
incontournables quand même un pédophile
l'impunité ne pouvez pas vous pouvez pas
dire je connais bien
si vous pouvez pas dire ce que vous
venez dire voilà non mais voilà non ce
qui est vrai quand même c'est qu'on
découvre malgré tout dans d'autres
françois et je ne veux pas taper sur les
morts je fais assez bien sûr les vivants
enfin on découvre des bouquets il a eu
sa première femme à 13 ans on découvre
qu'il a planqué ses enfants parce qu'il
est surtout pas que les fans le savent
on découvre sa tâche
ce vocabulaire vous le faites vous fait
que les chiens il a quitté sa femme qui
avait gagné l'eurovision au téléphone le
raccrochant n'est pas ce qu'il
supportait pas oui pardon mes enfants
redécouvrent kahn que ce mec était pas
quelqu'un de très bien ça alors ça
suffit
ab oui on en a parlé en mal
donc arrêtez de parler de saussure les
morts c'est bon c'est fait s'est passé
ouais ouais on fait tout le monde alors
lui les autres maisons mais j'ai pas
qu'ils sont bien ou pas bien ça suffit
il ya longtemps mais il a fait ce qu'il
a fait ça et patin couffin d'aller
regarder ses esprits et donc sur un
événement douloureux de sa vie le jour
on lui a retiré son enfant viable
une bd vivait mais lorsque j'ai voulu le
voir le prendre dans mes bras
ils n'ont pas voulu c'est le médecin qui
est tout de suite parlé de l'adoption
j'ai eu à faire un médecin qui s'est mis
au dessus des lois
quand claude est mort j'ai tout perdu
j'avais perdu mon enfant j'avais perdu
j'aurais perdu le père de mon enfant
macedo témoignages poignants qu'on a vu